The Joe Rogan Experience how much Joe
have you looked at
um
you know Larry Fink Soro State Street
you know Vanguard BlackRock how much
have you looked at what they're doing
and how what their ties are I've looked
at it yeah yeah they're pretty much
running everything yeah
S P 500 you know the number that
88 of the companies on S P 500 88 of
them the largest shareholder
of those companies is either State
Street BlackRock or Vanguard 88 of them
okay
and then you see their influence in
defense contracts okay so we went
through ideas I'm like let me see if
this these guys this ESG Larry Fang
Vanguard State Street if they have any
influence on Military contract defense
contract
if you Google the largest shareholder
for Raytheon
three out of the four top shareholders
of Raytheon BlackRock State Street and
uh Vanguard it could be top three with
Raytheon but I think it's three out of
four
if you go look up General Dynamics if
you go look up Boeing if you go look up
you know Northrop Grumman okay
and then you work backwards and you say
okay
how much money is that in the in what
these guys are doing
you'll find the r you know the amount of
money we spent in our military 744
billion dollars on how much we're making
from defense but you'll see some numbers
saying last year is 13 of our GDP which
is around 850 billion dollars that's
more than the next 10 combined
we gave more money to Ukraine
then Russia spent on their military last
year
and when you look at these contracts
then you're like okay Fink is there
these guys are there okay let's go look
at Hollywood
same thing you see there let's go look
at Pharmaceutical
let's go look at this and you're like
wait a minute
these guys essentially have a monopoly
well how big is Blackrock
10 trillion dollars how big is 10
trillion dollars only two countries
have a bigger GDP
than what BlackRock has assets under
management U.S and China that's how bad
big black rock is so then they went and
they started getting all these other
guys to sign on and say hey we want you
to participate with the same thing as
well with ESG and they ended up having I
think that 31 signers I think end of
2022 they got 60 uh something signers
for a total of 70 trillion dollars of
assets under management that they're
controlling so now they're controlling
other places and just recently if you
saw the rebuilding of Ukraine did you
see this contract rebuilding of Ukraine
400 billion dollar contract BlackRock
and Chase is helping rebuild Ukraine
and then okay I'm not a conspiracy
theorist but what the hell is going on
here
they have that much control
to get everybody to do what they want
them to do yes
so Dylan Mulvaney who cares why but
light
how does that tie up you got the Dei the
HRC the human rights and all this stuff
and then you go even deeper which is
even the crazier part with you know the
the education schools like you know the
biggest Union we have in America I think
it's National Education something Nea is
the largest Union we have three million
teachers are part of that Union
and and you look at that and you go
deeper in that with open society and
who's funding it who's the money behind
these organizations comes back Soros
Soros Soros
how do you feel about the kind of power
they have right now to fight against
them because this isn't like a
billionaire can come out and say I'm
going to go up against these guys they
don't have a little bit of money a
billionaire to these guys is nothing
they got the kind of control that
can make companies fire boards they can
replace CEOs they can replace leaders if
they don't like they have their hands so
much into it where many times when
people say they the people of power the
people of power I'm kind of like who are
the people of Power are you convinced
these guys are really running the world
or what do you think about what some of
these bigger companies are doing like
State Street Vanguard and BlackRock well
they certainly have massive amounts of
influence what do you think they're
doing
it's it's the question is how do you
fight it like for example the way we
fight mainstream is by what the show
that we do and we have to be patient
it's going to take two three four five
ten twenty years now you have some
influence right okay we can fight there
is an actual strategy on how to fight
that no problem you got a kid in school
who's a bully he's bigger than you he
keeps bullying you you have a strategy
on how to beat the guy you take a year
Jiu Jitsu two years this this that boom
one fight he knows I'm never gonna touch
you again screw this thing I'm not doing
this no more right there is a play to it
when you have this much Joe 88 of s p
500 companies
that is a form of a monopoly if I'm a
president whether it's a trump or
whoever else goes out there and does it
our Monopoly law in America is 50 they
say 50 like if you tie and said at what
point is a 50 I've done calls with the
FTC like we had one of our guys
technology we were using the FTC called
and said hey we want to have a call with
you because they're thinking about
buying this other technology company and
we're worried it's going to be a
monopoly so we had the call okay at the
end of the call with us with a bunch of
different people we said we love their
product we love their product that deal
didn't end up happening okay the
Monopoly law some of these guys are
influencing it
but they say 50 as a monopoly law do you
know how many people in America have an
iPhone versus Droid you know what the
numbers market shares in America with
iPhones I think it's like 60. 58 60 that
is already a monopoly but who's knocking
on the door of
Apple Tim Cook said hey Tim you got 58
that's breaking a monopoly law nobody is
I think someone's got a break apart you
know in 1993
I don't know which Senator it was they
these guys that were trying to get the
defense contractors to be better at the
pricing what they were charging because
they were overcharging DOD and the ODP
people don't know what the hell is going
on they're like yeah okay how much 68
million dollars do it 1.2 billion
dollars do it I'm not going to over
negotiate the money
they took 51 defense companies
and they brought it down to only five
it's only five companies right now when
you want to buy anything
think about that so defense contractors
is five
we know how these guys make money
earlier you know I was asking a question
why do you think vaccine are you like
Pat that's how they make their money
right I mean if they if you and I run a
hotel rooms are empty we're not making
money we need people to stay in dorms if
you and I are running a hospital or any
people on the beds to make money yeah if
there's no people on the beds we ain't
making money
if these five contractors are fighting
for
744 billion dollars what do they want
more of Wars they want more people down
you know the Papa John's saying better
ingredients better Pizza Papa John's you
know these guys is more Wars more people
dying more profits defense contractors
right that's a valid concern that I have
because behind closed doors this whole
military industrial complex when you
look at the numbers
whoever becomes the president
unfortunately
this guy's an anti-establishment
president good unfortunately if you're
an anti-establishment president
everyone's going to come after you
especially these military defense
contractors
so if a president got up and said if I'm
gonna be the president here's what we're
going to be doing we have to look at all
the contracts you can't overcharge us we
have to open it up you have to sell some
of your companies you have to let them
be independent again you have to do this
you have to let them go public separate
whatever way you got to break them apart
to have competition again
because we don't have that today you
know so that is a major concern where
we say we have a commander-in-chief but
really the commander-in-chief
is Larry Fink
today
the guy running BlackRock is really the
president of the United States
if we look at the kind of influence he's
got in every industry Joe
and he's like well you know I kind of
feel bad I'm ashamed that all the
weaponization the word you know ESG is
being used and all this other stuff and
Elon tweeted about the yes yet I don't
know if you remember when Elon tweeted
about yes she's saying the s in ESG is
satanic
okay so this is a part where even a
Charlie Munger
who is Warren Buffett's partner says
look I love Larry Fink
but I'm not interested in having an
emperor some words like that he said
about Larry Fink so this motive and by
the way Larry Fink is an interesting guy
because he majored in college political
science his aspirations was politics
he accidentally got into money
and he learned the trade and then he
lost 100 million dollars at 36 years old
I think and then he teams up with
Schwartzman and they start this company
and after a couple years they got 5
billion under management 8 billion and
32 billion and then they have a
difference because you know he wants to
give equity and Jamie's you know
schwartzman's like No Name They separate
but influence of politics you get into
business you're a billionaire
it's you sorrows
so I'm I'm extremely concerned about
what these guys are up to and
we think our president is the most
powerful person that person is not
because being a closer is going to be
like look
guys let's relax that guy's only going
to be there for four to eight years
we're gonna be all right he'll be out
we're running the world we're okay we
were running America but now we're
running the world we control all the
ETFs in America we're controlling all
this stuff
everyone has to come through to us and
we can tell everybody what to do because
everybody fears not getting money from
us from being downgraded a Tesla on ESG
score is nothing but a Philip Morris
gets an a rating how the hell the
company that's Philip Morris has a
better environmental social governance
score Dei you know not Dei but the CEI
the score they give it over Tesla so
they can bully some of these guys let me
ask you this what do you think the goal
of ESG is what why do you think they're
establishing these sort of parameters
like why why is ESG a thing and what's
the benefit of it for them so Schultz
said something very interesting Schultz
says look these guys are driven by money
they're not going to do anything to
destroy an economy to lose their own
money because they want that I said okay
so very good Andrew Schultz so that's a
very good point uh uh you know on what
you're saying fine
so you know you know how sometimes
Michael Jackson you see the interview
with him with kids
oh they're just sleeping in the bed
that's all it is and we're just having a
great time and we're storytelling and
like
ever I get it you know it's a little
weird you got a seven eight-year-old 10
year old kid sleeping in your bed and
you know all this stuff and I'm just
it's a little bit fishy what you're
talking about here it's not normal well
if you're in Hollywood and you've slept
with as many people as these people's
sleep and it eventually you have to have
other options because what else do you
have to try new things how many
threesomes have you had how many this
how many that so you start trying all
these other things and sometimes these
guys go to such and such place
doesn't matter it's kind of weird and
fishy right on what you want to do great
okay
so why these guys doing what they're
doing
you have all the money in the world
you live in a 100 million dollar house
not you Larry Fink and some of these
guys I'm not I don't know if he lives in
100 million dollars but you've got some
money to live in 100 million what else
do you need right you got nice cars
Jamie diamonds got a 900 million dollar
art collection according to an article
it's a nice art collection right
you go to all the nice restaurants you
meet Prime Ministers you meet presidents
and maybe there comes a time when you're
looking at a couple of these guys
they're presidents and prime ministers
and you tell yourself
I'd be a better president than you bro
how the hell am I not reading the
country or they tell themselves
you think you're a president
you're not a president you work for me
what else is the motive
but esj how does that factor but that
the point is control is what I'm saying
so the motive becomes control more than
money after you have all the money in
the world what's next
it's got to be control or a true vision
so a Sorrows when you're talking ESG
that story is a completely different
story you ever heard soros's interview
with 60 minutes where he says I see
myself as a God have you ever seen this
interview or what he says no really he
said he sees himself as a God oh my God
Jamie do you mind pulling up the
quote I think it's if you type in LA
Times Sorrows God
if you type in LA Times
Sorrows God when you hear what he says
it's like the second to the last
paragraph all the way to the bottom
the guy asked a question you know about
who he views himself as I want to I want
to quote it properly exactly what he
says and is there a video of him saying
yeah a 60 Minute there's a video as well
so if you go all the way to the bottom
I'm gonna go a little bit higher go a
little bit higher in the quote I'm going
to answer next to my friends
now go a little higher I think it's a
little higher
keep going higher
keep going higher keep going higher keep
going higher
prevalent values a little higher and
higher there's a part what he says
uh keep going what year is this article
by the way is this and it's a it's an
old article it's supposed to be 2004.
that's the one this is the one
uh okay right there it seems that Soros
believes he was annoyed anointed by God
I fancied myself as some kind of a God
if truth be known I carried some rather
potent Messianic fantasies with me from
childhood which I felt I had to control
otherwise they might get me in trouble
and then on the next line one asked by
Britain's Independent Newspaper to
elaborate on the passage sources it is
sort of a disease when you consider
yourself some kind of a God the creator
of everything but I feel comfortable
about it now since I began to live it
out